a great place to start in researching
your distribution plan is through Google
Trends Google Trends is a completely
free service that allows you to see the
popularity of search terms in relation
to the total volume of search terms
across the world and in various
languages Google processes over 40,000
search queries every single second and
they're willing to share those insights
with you the reason why this is a great
place to start is that not only can you
see some really interesting things from
all of these search queries like the
most searched topic of the day but you
can also see the history of these search
terms and of related terms for your
business so I have Ronnie here with me
let's use her expertise to dive into
Google Trends a little bit let's go to
Google Trends and see what comes up
let's go to explore topics and type in
Pet Sitting so we see here that interest
over time is relatively consistent
although I see that there are some pigs
yeah that's interesting if you look at
the dates yeah you can see that there is
a pig every summer oh yeah
so people are searching more for Pet
Sitting during their summer vacations
yeah maybe not as much during their
holiday vacations that's interesting
yeah let's scroll down so what are these
regional interests here we can see it
where the search term is most popular
so like the United States is most
popular yeah you can see here the United
States it has 100 so this is where the
search is most common the place with the
greatest volume will always have 100 and
then all the other numbers here are
always relative to the 100 number ok so
we see that people in the United States
Canada Australia and even the United
Kingdom I guess are the most interested
in Pet Sitting not exactly we can assume
that these countries are the top ones to
search this exact search term in English
so it's not that surprising that the top
countries are english-speaking countries
let's make sure we compare apples to
apples so either we compare few
different english-speaking regions or we
decide to compare between different
search terms so let me click on the
United States
see a breakdown so pet-sitting is the
most popular in New Hampshire it seems
in North Carolina Arizona Colorado yeah
actually we can choose these regions as
our pilot regions or something like that
oh that's awesome let's go back for a
second for the worldwide view this can
also give us insights on popular related
terms let's go down this can also give
us insights about related searches and
related terms so in our messaging and
tagline and wording that we wasn't using
our website and messaging we can use not
only dog-sitting but also pet sitters
pet sitter pet care pet sitting service
--is and other terms that people really
search more it's cool how they bring it
down I'm sure that'll help you develop
what keywords you're gonna want to use
let's go back to the top I want to show
you the categories section here yeah
this can be very helpful in research so
we have options like hobbies and leisure
pets and animals jobs and education
categories are important if you want to
expand into the Google Display Network
the Google Display Network allows you to
place display ads on related websites
and you can choose where to advertise
based on categories what we learn here
will help us choose a category of
websites to advertise them clearly pets
and animals seems relevant to us but
look under jobs and education the
interesting pet sitting shut up after 28
that's interesting I would have never
thought to look at this so what else
could find in web search just a second
before we do that let's go back to jobs
and education and go back to all
categories yeah so this will show us the
interest level based on specific types
of searches for example if we learn that
our top search term is super popular in
image search
- we might consider this as another
advertising option we can make sure that
there are plenty of relevant images that
will link back to our websites another
cool thing you can do is actually to
compare different search terms and it's
not necessarily for image search it's
gonna be for web search too let's go
back to a web search and yeah let's just
add another term like dog services and
it's interesting to see that maybe few
years ago the demand was quite similar
but recently you can see that the demand
for the red one which is dog service
is much higher than faceting it's
interesting yeah pet-sitting seems to
slowly be declining yeah so whether you
have to decide how to phrase your
tagline or which keywords to choose for
your campaign either way it helps you
focus better sometimes it can really
show you the demand of the market I mean
if people search more for product X or
product Y so you can develop the product
that has more demand on Google search
demand could be seasonal as you can see
here so you could use that either to
choose which F to develop or at least
plan your advertising campaigns around
things people search for on holidays or
in the summer or around back-to-school
for example so for us if we see that
during the summer people are searching
more for Pet Sitting we know that this
is the time where we want to really
really heat our campaigns it's
surprising to see how seasonal Pet
Sitting is so maybe we should target
families more than just business people
yeah we learned something look at that
okay well let's go to a question about
this okay so we saw this tool I think is
pretty awesome and I could have a lot of
fun with it but I think it's time for
you to explore it a little bit more I
want you to go to Google Trends and
explore a search term that's related to
your app if you don't have one go ahead
and use a barkman but don't use the same
search term we did then fill in the
blanks below first I want you to tell us
what term you used then what city was
that term most popular in then check out
the related terms what are the two most
popular related terms add one here and
here and finally just for fun what was
the most surprising thing you found out
when exploring Google Trends